des graffitis pour décorer la ville
l'initiative a été lancée à la verrière
par l'association prévert en partenariat
avec l'artiste soleil erdf dessine ta
ville c'est le nom du projet qui permet
à plusieurs jeunes de la ville de
laisser libre cours à leur âme
artistique sur deux transformateurs nous
vous en parlions en mars déjà lors d'un
reportage sur le premier d'entre eux
c'était au bois de l'étang mercredi 27
avril c'était au tour de celui d'orly
parc de profiter de cette mise en beauté
écouter la maire de la commune elle est
au micro de camille lambert il ya déjà
deux fresques qui sont très différentes
l'une de l'autre donc c'est bien c'est
l'imagination qui est qui prend le
dessus et enfin visiblement les jeunes
qui ont mal à son heureux
d'avoir fait de montrer son fier et ça
ça compte beaucoup il n'avait d'autre
prévue pour l'instant et puis vu vu que
ça se passe très très bien on va voir
quelle quelle autre partenariat on peut
faire dans le temps toujours dans la
même veine on a des artistes qui
commencent à y prendre goût donc il faut
continuer